[Música]
Olá,
minhas amigas, meus amigos. Sejam muito
bem-vindos para mais uma live. Como é de
praxa, eu peço para vocês me informarem
como está o áudio. Estou com microfone
profissional aqui, mas é sempre
importante vocês me dizerem se tá tudo
OK pra gente ajustar caso não esteja.
Esse microfone aqui é muito sensível ao
toque. Se eu tocar num ponto específico
dele, às vezes ele desativa, como
aconteceu na semana passada.
Mas eu já tô mais ligado.
Bem, medida que vocês vão entrando,
forem entrando, a gente vai vendo como é
que tá o áudio, mas eu já vou começar
respondendo as perguntas,
OK? Então, o
eu tô com uma situação aqui de
alternância de janela no computador
diferente e não sei se tá afetando o
áudio. Então, por favor, me digam nesse
momento, nesse exato momento, se vocês
estão escutando o meu áudio, tá?
Antônio Renato, áudio OK? Boa noite,
Antônio. Me diga, em algum momento
cortou o seu áudio ou o áudio tá vindo
tranquilo
o tempo todo?
Eliseu também presente. Boa noite,
Eliseu. Obrigado pela informação,
Eliseu. Bem, vamos então às perguntas.
Vocês vão me falando se tiver algum
problema no áudio. Primeira pergunta. A
modulação hormonal bioidêntica em
mulheres apenas é arriscada em caso de
risco de trombose, câncer de mama, útero
e ovários ou tem risco em outros casos?
Apesar de eu já ter tocado no assunto
antes,
poderia aprofundar um pouco sobre os
riscos gerais e exames.
Veja bem, o grande problema que nós
temos em relação aos dados de reposição
monal é que 80% da literatura sobre isso
é sobre a reposição monal que se fazia
até 2003, 2004, não é que se faz até
hoje, mas era predominante naquela
época, que é reposição hormonal vior
oral de estrogênio em conjugado de égua
mais progestina. Então, todos esses
dados que nós temos de trombose, de
câncer de mama, de câncer de ovário,
problemas aí eventualmente
cardiovasculares, é tudo em cima disso,
tá? Desse tipo de reposição que era
feita antigamente. Temos poucos dados
sobre reposição transdêmica
com hormônios bidêntes ou
isomoleculares, mas o dado que nós temos
dizem que eles são muito mais seguros.
Então, quando utilizamos hormônios
isomoleculares ou
também conhecido como bioidênticos pela
via da pele transdérmica,
isso tô falando do estradiol, do estriol
e da testosterona, tá? Queesses
hormônios é obrigatório você fazer
transdérmico
ou pode até ser sublingual, mas eu não
recomendo. Então, a progesterona e o
deia você tem segurança de fazer via
oral, ok?
Então, o perfil de segurança pela via
transdâmica do estradiol, estriol e
testosterona é bem maior do que seria se
você fizesse uso via oral. a literatura
internacional de 2024, também estudos
recentes que foram publicados no Brises
Medical Journal. Então, confirmam que a
via transdâmica
ela praticamente elimina o risco de
tromoembolismo venoso que acontecia com
os estrogênios orais, daqueles grandes
estudos que foram publicados no início
dos anos 2000, que foi o exame chinês,
desculpa, o estudo chinês e o estudo da
Inglaterra, tá?
Então, quando a gente não tem a
passagem, a primeira passagem hepática,
esses hormônios são muito mais seguros.
Então, o que acontece? O metabolismo na
passagem hepática, quando você engole o
hormônio e ele é absorvido pela mucosa
do intestino, ele passa pelo fígado
através da veia porta. É isso que
provoca o metabolismo desses hormônios,
os estrogênios, né, e a testosterona,
causando metabó indesejados.
E esses metabólos indesejados podem
afetar os fatores de coagulação e
aumentar as proteínas protrombóticas.
Isso não acontece quando você faz essa
posição desses hormônios pela pele,
ok? Então, pela transdérmica bioident
isomolecular, os riscos se reduzem
muito.
É praticamente risco cardiovascular
inexistente. Existe alguns estudos com
testosterona aí já injetável
intramuscular e que sugerem que a
testosterona poderia ter um papel aí de
aumentar a aterosclerose, o entupimento
das artérias. Mas isso é contestado,
porque tem outros estudos que falam o
contrário, que a testosterona poderia
proteger os vasos, artérias.
Então é um assunto não pacificado na
literatura, mas se você usar a
testosterona embaixo dosagem
transdérmica, ela é bem mais segura e
tem um risco cardiovascular muito
pequeno. Na verdade, no meu ponto de
vista, até aumenta
a saúde geral, diminui o risco
cardiovascular. Então, estudos também
mostram que o estraggiol transdêmico
pela pele não apenas aumenta o risco,
não apenas não aumenta o risco de
infarto AVC, mas pode ter um efeito
cádioprotetor
que não é tão grande, mas tem, tá? Então
isso contrasta radicalmente com os
riscos vistos no estudo grande lá, um
dos dois grandes estudos de 2002, 2003,
que é o estudo do WH, né, ou WHI,
né, da Associação das Enfermeiras lá dos
Estados Unidos, no qual foi utilizado
estrogênios equínos, né, estrogênios de
égua conjugados.
Existiria também naquela época um risco
aumentado de doença biliar, tá? De
formar pedra na vesícula com estrogênio
oral. Só que esse risco de doença
biliária é mínimo com os transvérmicos.
Por quê? Porque a via oral, que não deve
ser utilizada por estrogênio, aumenta a
síntese de colesterol biliar via
metabolismo hepático, mas transdêmicos
tem o metabolismo biliar normal,
tá? Então existe também uma história que
esses
hormônios via oral também afetavam a
função hepática. Porém, via
transdâmêmica não há alteração
significativa da função hepática, as
enzimas hepáticas ficam estáveis, não há
estresse metabólico no fígado, pelo pelo
menos eu nunca vi na prática.
Riscos que permanecem com transdêmico
isomolecular, tá? com os hormônios
bioidênticos na pele. Câncer de mama não
é nulo, existe sim esse risco, mas ele é
bem menor do que era antes com a
progestina, né? As progesteronas que não
são bidênticas, são sintéticas, que a
gente chama de progestina,
ok?
Então, quando a gente faz a associação
do transdêmico
estrogênio com a progesterona
transdêmica também, o progesterona oral,
o risco é bem menor. Óbvio que existe
ainda um pouco de risco se essa mulher
tiver mutação genética do P53
ou BRCA1, BRCA2
ou se essa mulher tiver muito inflamada
ou muito intoxicada, tá?
Então, dados mostram a ausência de risco
de câncer de mama.
os pelos 5 anos com a combinação de
progesterona e estradial bioidênticos
feitos da maneira correta. E o estrial,
por ser um estrogênio fraco,
especificamente tem um perfil ainda mais
seguro por sua afinidade preferencial
com os receptores beta, que são os menos
proliferativos do que os alfa.
Em relação ao câncer de dométrio, desde
que utilizemos progesterona oral
micronizada, dose adequada, né, sem ser
muito elevada,
não passar de 200 mg, na verdade
raramente passo de 100 mg, né, quando é
via oral,
a proteção endometrial é completa
e existe uma discussão na literatura se
o transdérmico protege ou não protege o
endométrio, tá? Isso depende da fonte
que vocês foram consultar. Vai dizer que
o oral só que protege, o transdérêmico
não protege. Mas aí, por exemplo, Lúcio
Lemo já defende cunhas e dentes que o
creme transnic progesterona poderia
oferecer sim essa proteção, tá? Então eu
faria o quê, né? Eu faria uso conjunto
de oral, tá? Com o transdêmico em boa
parte das mulheres aí ou até somente o
oral da progesterona bioidêntica.
existe um risco de pepolasia endometrial
que não é câncer, né? É o é a
proliferação do endométrio sem câncer. E
para isso é importante fazer
monitoramento com tração transvaginal
todos os anos, né? A espessura do
endométrio deve permanecer abaixo de 5
mm se tiver usando o contínuo, né? Se
por acaso o doméro ficar mais grosso do
que isso, aí você precisa eh parar e
reavaliar aí o tratamento hormonal.
Então, como é que a gente monitora aí? É
complicado porque tem a turma que
defende o sangue, tem a turma que
defende a salir. Os dois têm problemas,
essa que é a grande realidade. Eu já fui
mais defensor da saliva no passado do
que eu sou hoje. Eu já vi também que tem
problemas na saliva. Eu acho, se puder
utilizar os três métodos, melhor ainda
você utilizar a dosagem sérica, a
dosagem salivar e os metabólitos
urinários para quem tem recurso, porque
o plano de saúde não vai liberar.
metabólito urinário e não vai liberar
saliva.
Mas a gente procura manter o estradiol
sérico com a reposição, se for esse o
único exame disponível por volta de 60 a
100 picog por m e a progesterona
acima de 2 ng por ml, porque aí vai ter
aquela ação protetora cerebral também.
E a testosterona as mulheres é bem
variável aí, mas eu colocaria aqui pelo
menos uns 40 ou 50 picogram por ml, né,
de testosterona, não passando acima de
100.
Fazer o controle anual, né, com
ultrassom eh mamário. E se puder fazer
mamografia só a cada 3 anos para evitar
a radiação, melhor ainda, tá?
pode acontecer de aumentar a densidade
da mama com a reposição eh hormonal que
eh tem que ser monitorado. Daí
o tração tem que ser o transaginal tem
que ser anual também, fazer os exames de
sangue, né, eh comuns, né, para ver a
como é que está a parte bioquímica.
E também vê a função tirodiana, porque
tem uma ligação entre os hormônios
tirodianos e a progesterona. proon ela
acaba aumentando a atividade dos
hormônios
tiroidianos. Então tem que ficar atento
quanto a isso, porque se for uma mulher,
por exemplo, que tá
fazendo eh reposição hormonal
tiroidiana, pode ser que tem que fazer
um ajuste para mais, parece para menos,
né? Reduzir a dose dos hormônios
tiroidianos.
Muito importante buscar uma farmácia
magistral com boa qualidade de
formulação, né? que tem muita variedade
de farmácia para farmácia, tem muitas
tecnologias diferentes dos gels, né, de
ou géis, né, eh, de nanopartícula ou de
não nanopartícula, de liberação
lipossomal ou não. Então, tem que ficar
muito atento quanto a essas tecnologias.
A região mais apropriada para aplicar é
na parte interna das coxas ou baixo
ventre. Eu gosto da parte interna das
coxas porque é uma área que tem mais
gordura e absorve melhor.
Eh, tem a maior acessibilidade de
absorção na parte interna das coxas,
mas também pode ser feito do uso
intravaginal, né, para as mulheres que
não se incomodam com isso.
Certo? Então, chega desse assunto que eu
já gastei quase 20 minutos falando dessa
questão aí. Próxima pergunta é dito.
Deixa eu ver. Vocês estão escutando bem,
né? Não tá tendo nenhum problema.
Ninguém tá falando que tem problema. Boa
noite, Alice VG. Boa noite, Enil. Boa
noite, Dra. Ana Paula.
Próxima pergunta. É dito que o
carcinômio base celular, que é o câncer
de pele mais comum, né, e o mais
tranquilo, digamos assim, que raramente,
muito raramente ele metastatiza.
Então, esse ccinoma base celular aparece
devido à exposição sol.
Mas na medicina integrativa se sabe que
o sol não é maléfico. Depende. Tudo em
excesso pode ser maléfico. Inclusive é
dito pelo Dr. Lair que esse tipo de
carcinoma aparece mais em pessoas não
expostas ao sol. Hum. É bem assim, tá?
Depende. Se for uma pessoa tipo um
pescador
que se expõe ao sol todo santo dia, sim,
eles têm uma proteção maior contra o
carcinoma base celular. Mas se for uma
pessoa, por exemplo, que fica o ano
inteiro sem pegar sol e de repente fica
10 dias torrando na praia, aí é
diferente, tá? Então tem essa distinção
muito importante. Se você não pega sol
no dia a dia, não tome sol muitas horas
nas férias, porque sua pele não tá
acostumada, tá? Então você pode ter sim
um base celular por uma exposição muito
intensa para uma pele que não tá
acostumada.
Então, qual seria a razão do
aparecimento desse carcinoma se não sol?
Vamos lá. Então,
existe então uma diferença fundamental
da maneira como nós na medicina
funcional ou integrativa enxergamos esse
assunto, mas temos que ter bom senso,
tá? Não é tudo da medicina ortodoxa que
nós vamos jogar fora.
A literatura científica mais recente
aponta para um paradoxo. Então, pessoas
com deficiência de vitamina Didado têm
maior incidência de carcinoma. É o que
eu tava falando, é o cara que fica no
escritório o ano inteiro e só toma sol
nas férias. Esse cara vai ter
deficiência de vitamina D. E se fori
exposto a muito sol de uma vez, ele pode
até pegar um cascinoma base celular. OK?
Tem um estudo de Stanford que mostrou
que pacientes com câncer de pele que
evitam o sol tem três vezes mais
probabilidade de ter deficiência de
vitamina D.
Isso sugere que não é o sol em si o
problema, mas sim a forma como o nosso
organismo lida com a exposição solar.
A verdadeira causa do ccidão bascelular
pode ser relacionada a múltiplos fatores
que vão atuar em conjunto, vão convergir
para criar um ambiente propício ao
desenvolvimento do tumor. Então,
primeiro nós temos a disfunção
mitocondrial que tá por trás de muitas
doenças crônicas, tá por trás da
fibromialgia, tá por trás da enxaqueca,
tá por trás de fadiga crônica.
Então essa disfunção mitocondrial e
estresse oxidativo desempenha um papel
importante. Quando as mitocôndrias, que
são as usinas de energia nossas células,
não funcionam de maneira adequada, tem
uma produção excessiva de radicais
livres, né? Também conhecido como
espécies reativas de oxigênio. Então
esses radicais livres danificam o nosso
DNA, danificam a parede celular,
danificam uma série de proteínas também.
Pessoas têm síndrome metabólica, tem
mais estresse oxidativo. Lembrando que
síndrome metabólica são cinco
eh fatores que se você preencher três
dos cinco, você já tá falando em círom
metabólica, que é tlices alto, HDL
baixo, glicose alta, cintura abdominal
aumentada e hipertensão arterial.
Então, se você tiver resistência
insulina, cina metabólica, inflamação
crônica de baixo grau, você vai ter
muito mais estresse oxidativo e isso vai
aumentar o risco de câncer ou carcinoma
base celular. A exposição a toxinas que
são quase sempre ocultas no nosso
ambiente, né? Pouca gente pesquisa isso,
né? Por exemplo, arsênio ou arsênico.
Você deve pesquisar na urina, deve
pesquisar também no cabelo. Tem várias
toxinas que são derivados do petróleo ou
dos agrotóxicos que não são pesquisados
de rotina e podem ser causas de vários
cânceres, inclusive baselular. Então, o
arcênico, eu já peguei muito paciente
com arsênico aumentado, ele tá presente
em água contaminada, em alguns alimentos
pode induzir o carcinoma baselular,
mesmo em áreas do corpo que não são
expostas ao sol.
Então, estudos mostram que o arsênico
causa disfunção imunológica, estresse
gritativo, alterações na metilação do
DNA. Então, o DNA ele precisa do
processo de metilação para regular a
expressão gênica. Se falta metilação no
DNA, o que acontece é que genes que não
deveriam ser expressos são expressos e
isso bagunça a replicação celular e pode
gerar câncer. OK?
A imunossupressão crônica causada pela
deficiência de vitamina D ligada às
pessoas que não tomam sol também é um
fator de risco para base celular,
porque a deficiência de vitamina D
compromete a nossa resposta, nossa
defesa imune, especialmente a função das
células T.
Então, quando o sistema de defesa tá
debilitado, seja por deficiência
nutricional, estresse crônico ou os
medicamentos que vão suprimir o sistema
imune os imunosupressores, as células
anormais não são eliminadas de maneira
eficiente. As células anormais também
conhecidas como células senestescentes,
tá?
Quarto, inflamação crônica silenciosa
por fatores que eu já falei, por
intoxicação ambiental e estresse
oxidativo pela questão aí da resistência
insulínica ou cin metabólica. Mas
especificando um pouquinho mais sobre a
dieta que eu saio de falar aqui para
vocês, uma dieta pró-inflamatória, rica
em açúcar, alimentos processados,
refinados, industrializados,
o glúten, que vocês sabem muito bem e a
casina presente nos laticínios.
Isso pode criar um microambiente que
favorece progressão tumoral. Essa
inflamação tá intimamente ligado à
resistência insulínica e a síndrome
metabólica.
Estudos recentes dizem que níveis muitos
elevados de vitamina D, acima de 75
nanomoles por litro, tá? que essa
unidade aqui é diferente do que a gente
tá acostumado, que seria aí por volta de
acima de 110 da
unidade que nós estamos acostumados,
poderiam também estar associadas a maior
incidência de castronoma base pelular em
algumas populações. Isso é um dado até
curioso, né? É uma coisa que eu
recentemente me deparei, então não é bom
também. A vitamina D tá muito muito
alta, OK?
Então, mantenha a sua vitamina no sangue
entre 40 e 70 ng por dclro. Aqui eu tô
falando 75 nanomes por litro, que vai
dar mais ou menos 110, 120
da unidade de medida que a gente tá
acostumado.
Então é muito importante ter equilíbrio,
não é só tacar a vitamina D para dentro
de qualquer jeito.
E tem a questão também de algumas
pessoas que tm a mutação do VDR, que é o
receptor da vitamina D, e outras que
também tm mutações na transformação
do 25 hidróxis vitamina D no calcetriol,
né, que é a forma ativa, mesmo que essa
ativação final é feita no rim. Então, às
vezes, as pessoas tem deficiência da
enzima que converte o calciol em
calcitriol e acumula calcidiol no sangue
e essa pessoa não tem a forma final da
vitamina D que realmente protege ela.
Então, é muito importante manter a nossa
vitamina D no sangue, como eu falei,
entre 40 e 70 Ng por m,
evitar a suplimentação excessiva, tomar
pelo menos 15 minutos de sol por dia. Se
você tiver pele clara, pele escura, pode
tomar uns 40 minutos se você quiser.
Importante uma dieta rica e
antioxidantes, fitonutrientes, né, com
vegetais coloridos, porque os vegetais
coloridos vão ter fitonutrientes
diferentes,
diferentes substâncias que vão ter
funções antioxidantes
naturais,
os polifenóis, né, que a gente chama.
Importante também para quem tem
disfunção mitocondrial
utilizar, né, as substâncias que
aumentam a função mitocondrial, o caso
da comenzima Q10, do PQQ, do NAD, é o
caso do alicarnitina,
terribose, creatina,
são excelentes, né? E o Nadima lembrando
também que tem o NMN, né, que é
nicotinamida
mon monucleotídio,
nicotinamida ribusídio que são derivados
da vitamina B de bola 3. Se você não
tiver cascalho, bala na agulha para
comprar esses daí que são caros, pode
comprar vitamina B3 na forma de
exanicotinatos deusitol, que também vai
ter um efeito de aumentar o NAD mais
indiretamente, só que vai ter mais
para chegar lá.
fazendo detox, se for necessário de
metais pesados e substâncias poluentes
orgânicos persistentes.
Melhorar uma função imune. Aí você pode
utilizar prebióticos, são as fibras,
probióticos, pode utilizar,
né,
própolis verde. Você pode utilizar
também aí em alguns casos, né,
dependendo da situação, até a efectina
que tem se mostrado aí antioxidante,
imunomoduladora, mas é polêmico, né?
Controle da resistência insulina, né?
Controlando os níveis de açúcar no
sangue, de glicose, dieta baixa
carboidrato, cotando os alimentos
processados industrializados.
Pode tentar uma dieta citogênica, pode
tentar uma dieta carnívora, uma dieta
mediterrânea, uma dieta, né,
paleolítica, tem várias dietas aí que
você pode tentar. Jejun intermitente,
exercícios.
Então é isso que eu tinha para falar.
Lembrando que tem colega médico que teve
carcinoma base celular, não vou falar
quem é por ética, tomava bastante sol,
tá? Então cuidado também, não tomem
excesso de sol, tá? 10 a 15 minutos por
dia, se você tiver pele clara, tá? Ah,
mas aí tem os pescadores. Calma, gente.
Isso aí a gente tem que entender que
cada população do mundo tem uma
característica. Então, se o cara é
pescador, o pai foi pescador, o avô foi
pescador, ele tem uma genética já mais
corretamente falando, uma epigenética
favorável a tomar sol, tá? Então,
cuidado também com as afirmações aí
absolutas que você vem aí nos vídeos de
internet, né? Quanto mais simplificado é
o vídeo, mais absoluto é o que a pessoa
fala, mais popularidade
tem, porque você sabe que a borrice é
uma coisa que é muito popular, né? Não
chamando nenhum colega aí de propagador
de burrice, mas as pessoas têm uma
intolerância muito grande ao
contraditório e às nuances, né? E o
diabo está nos detalhes.
Próxima pergunta. Qual a opinião do
doutor sobre comer ovos todos os dias?
Eu como todos os dias, no mínimo 3 de
manhã, às vezes eu como até cinco ou
seis por dia. E a pessoa tá tá dizendo
que come de dois a quatro. Eu sou
totalmente favorável aos ovos, como eu
acabei de falar. Eu não acredito que os
ovos sejam bandido.
Os ovos são os polivitamínicos da
natureza. A literatura científica mais
recente tem confirmado cada vez mais o
que eu tenho defendido há vários anos.
Os ovos são alimento relativamente
barato, já foi mais, né? E são sim um
super alimento nutricional
e o medo que se criou em torno deles é
completamente errado, tá? tem estudos de
2024, 2025, incluindo uma metaanálise
que foi publicada este ano numa
universidade lá da
Austrália, né, da Monarch University,
que mostra que o consumo regular de ovos
está associado a uma redução de 27 a 29%
do risco de mortalidade cardiovascular
em adultos saudáveis.
Nós temos uma densidade nutricional
muito boa nos ovos. Cada ovo grande, né,
fornece cerca de 6 a 7 g de proteína de
alta qualidade biológica.
Lembrando, pessoal, se possível comem
ovos caipiras, tá? Da galinha que cisca,
que come o alimento ancestral dela.
Então, continuando, tem 125 g, desculpa,
miligram de colina, né, em cada ovo, que
é fundamental paraa função cerebral.
Tem luteína e zeachantina, que são super
antioxidantes, que são muito utilizados
para proteger os óleos e também o
cérebro. Vitamina D, apesar de não
recomendar que vocês contem com a
vitamina D ovos, né? Porque teria que
comer a granja inteira para poder
aumentar a vitamina D.
Então, o sol é fundamental, né? Mas já é
uma ajuda, né, o ovo em relação à
vitamina D, vitamina B12 também,
selênium e também o famoso ácido docosa
exenoico, que é o DHA, que é um tipo de
ômega-3 muito bom pro cérebro.
Lembrando, pessoal, que o colesterol do
sangue nada tem a ver com colesterol
geralmente, tá? Lógico tem exceções, mas
nada tem a ver com o colesterol da
dieta. Então o colesterol que você come
pouco dele,
vai participar do colesterol do sangue.
Ele tem impacto mínimo no colesterol do
sangue pra maioria das pessoas.
Lembrando isso, tá? Então o fígado é que
regula a produção de colesterol, que nós
sabemos que é matériapra. O organismo
precisa muito de colesterol para baina
de melina, paraa membrana celular, para
os sais biliares, para formar os
hormônios esteroida que são
sintetizados. na cortical, nas adrenais
e também na no testículo, no ovário.
Então, o colesterol é matéria prima por
um monte de coisa e o organismo
necessariamente tem que produzir,
portanto não é o ovo que vai te ferrar.
E vocês sabem que eu já falei em vídeos
anteriores que o problema não é o LDL
total, mas sim o LDL oxidado. E o LDL de
partículas pequenas e densas é que vai
oxidar. Então os ovos eles são
consumidos como parte de uma dieta sem
glúten e sem derivados lácteos, né?
Então ele não promove o padrão
aterogênico de partículas pequenas e
densas. E a colina, que teve estudos aí
no passado falando que a colina era do
mal, porque ela era metabolizada no
intestino com bactérias e formava aí um
metabólito que era aterogênico. Essa
história eh pelos últimos estudos não é
verdade, tá?
A colina e os falsofolipítes presentes
na gema são muito importantes no
metabolismo do colesterol, no
metabolismo lipítico saudável e na
prevenção da oxidação do LDL. Então,
estudos recentes confirmam que pessoas
consumindo ovos diariamente não têm
aumento no risco cardiovascular, mesmo
muitas que têm deslipidemia, né, ou
seja, doença ligado a desequilíbrio das
gorduras. Então, a presença de lecitina,
né, ácidos grassos insaturados e
apolipoproteínas nos ovos ajudam a
regular o metabolismo da gordura de
forma benéfica.
E eu recomendo consumir os ovos com a
gema um pouquinho assim,
digamos assim, crua, né? Ou seja, a gema
não totalmente frita, porque você vai
preservar melhor os nutrientes e
antioxidantes. Aí seria o ovo pochê ou
ovo cozido ou ovo frito, sem você eh
fritar demais a gema.
E na hora de fritar o ovo, use o óleo de
coco, use azeite de oliva, evite usar os
óleos comuns de sementes, como óleo de
soja, milho, canol e girassol, porque
esses óleos vegetais refinados podem
promover oxidação
e aumentar o de ômega-6 para ficar
desequilibrado em relação a
se puder comer os ovos com vegetais
ricos e antioxidantes, é melhor ainda.
Se puder comer ovo com abacate, por
exemplo, seria uma excelente pedida.
ovos com legumes e vegetais de cores
variadas.
Então é isso.
Pode consumir os seus dois a quatro ovos
por dia tranquilamente.
Prezado amigo, por favor,
o uso de peptídeos injetáveis
para fins de performance esportiva
é seguro ou apresenta colaterais como
uso de anaborizante?
Já temos estudos suficientes.
Esse é um problema, rapaz, né? Primeiro
que esses peptídios tinha disponível no
Brasil até 2 anos e meio mais ou menos.
Aí depois eles foram proibidos, mas era
mais via oral. Os injetáveis é muito
mais fundido no mercado americano.
Bem, com base na literatura mais
recente, eh pelo menos o que nós temos
aí disponíveis, disponível, né? é que os
pepitismos injetáveis para performance
esportiva não são exatamente seguros,
tá? No sentido estrito, ainda tem muitas
dúvidas,
ainda apresenta um perfil de efeitos
colaterais
substancialmente diferente e
só que é menos
intenso, com certeza que os
anabolizantes tradicionais.
Então, tem vários peptídeos aí, uma sopa
de letrinha aqui. Nem sei se eu vou
falar todas as combinações aqui de
letras porque é bem chatinho, né? Então,
você tem os peptídeos BPC 157, TB 500, o
IPELM, o MK 677, que é o Ipotamorin e
vários outros aí que eu não vou ficar
falando essa essa sopa de letrinha.
Então, a revisão sistemática mais
recente,
encontrou apenas um estudo clínico
adequado em humanos com o BPC 157 em 12
mulheres que tinham cistite
intersticial. Então, esse caso foi
utilizado para doença e não para
performance esportiva.
E todo o resto dos estudos desses
peptídios geralmente são em animais,
principalmente ratos.
E eu não sei porque que esse estudo tá
se arrastando, porque a gente fala de
peptídeo aí pelo menos uns 6 anos. Eu
não sei porque que esses estudos estão
se arrastando tanto em relação a
humanos.
Mas comparando com anabolizantes, os
esteroides anabolizantes vão atuar
substituindo de maneira direta, né, a
testosterona. Nós sabemos que temos
anabolizantes androgênicos
que imitam a testosterona e tem os
anabolizantes
que são mais eh na linha de hipertrofia
muscular, né, que são os não
androgênicos.
esses não androgênicos que não tem
aqueles efeitos colaterais que o
marubeiro não gosta, né, que é excesso
de pele oleosa, é inchaço,
eh no caso fica careca e tudo mais, só
que quem faz aí a os ciclos hormonais
tem que necessariamente associar
testosterona a outros anabolizantes
menos androgênicos, porque senão fica
impotente, né, com impotência sexual.
Masabizante suprime o eixo hormonal
natural, causam danos cardiovasculares,
causam toxicidade do fígado,
eh alteram muito a o perfil lipídico,
né? Baixam muito HDL e então isso é
muito ruim porque isso aumenta muito a
teseclerose, podem causar ginecomastia
se não tomar cuidado, né, que é petinho,
né, em homem.
Isso é muito comum da atrofia testicular
e alterações psiquiátricas também para
quem usa doses altas. Então os pepitíos
não têm esses problemas, eles são
sinalizadores que estimulam processos
naturais do corpo. Por exemplo, tem os
secretagogos de GH, né, que são
substâncias que imitam GH. Esses
peptídeos que imitam GH, eles vão
diretamente lá no receptor do hormônio
de crescimento
e não substituem a produção hidrógena. E
isso teoricamente resultaria em menos
supressão hormonal e menos efeitos
colaterais. Só que a gente tem poucos
estudos, esse que é o problema, né?
Então, por exemplo, BPC 157, o TB 500,
eles promove angiogênese, que é a
formação de vasos e regeneração
tecidual. Então, eles são utilizados
para doenças, né?
E teoricamente poderiam acelerar o
crescimento de tumores dormentes. Então,
isso não foi bem esclarecido ainda, né?
né? Pode ser que eles possam, em alguns
casos, aumentar os tumores. Os peptetos
relacionados ao GH, né, os secretagos de
GH, poderiam aumentar o risco de câncer
pelo estímulo generalizado do
crescimento celular.
E existe um problema muito sério de
qualidade e pureza dos produtos
disponíveis, porque eles são
underground, vem do mercado negro, então
é bem uma história aí dos anabolizantes,
então não há uma regulamentação muito
boa, então isso é muito também
preocupante.
Existe um problema de ética aí que a
esmagadora maioria dos estudos com BPC
157 foi feito por um grupo único da
Croácia.
Existe então um problema de viés, né, de
puxar sardinha pro próprio produto. O
MQ, o MK 677, que é o IBAMorem, né, ele
foi abandonado pela própria empresa que
desenvolveu, que foi a MERC. Não sabemos
exatamente aí as razões, mas
aparentemente não houveram benefícios
claros para eles.
E a o FD americano classificou o BPC 157
como substância de categoria 2 com risco
significativo de segurança. OK? Então
fique longe dessas substâncias. Você vai
conseguir comprar só no mercado negro,
né? Na internet. você não vai ter
muitas vezes aí
garantia de segurança, então eu ficaria
longe, tá? Não acho que vale a pena.
Acho só valeria a pena para um atleta
profissional e olhe lá, tá?
Que quer correr esse risco por razões
profissionais.
Muito bem, vamos pra próxima pergunta
aqui. Estou tratando o desbiove
e uma das bactérias que deu alta no
exame, deve ter feito o exame de
microbioma, foi metano breve bacter
smith. Tomei antibiótico, não sei qual
foi, não especificou aqui. Estou na
dieta low FOD MAP por 3 meses. Estou com
alguns sintomas novamente. Prata
coloidal seria uma opção para controlar
essa bactéria. E com relação ao óleo de
orégano.
Bem, o problema da prata coloidal é que
existe uma má vontade muito grande com
ela na literatura. O pessoal não tem
estudos assim muito elaborados sobre ela
e tem sempre aquela historinha quando
você vai pesquisar na internet, ah, tem
argilia, você vai se toxicar com metais,
com sais metal de
da prata, né? Mas isso eles estão
falando de um outro produto, porque a
prata coloidal de alta qualidade, sim, é
muito boa, tá? E existe pratacoloidal
de alta qualidade com nanotecnologia,
você pode comprar nos Estados Unidos. E
tem também bons fornecedores aí no
mercado brasileiro de prata coleid.
Então eu poderia até te dizer, tente
usar a prata coleidal. Eu gosto da prata
coloidal, mas eu tenho que ser sincero
para te dizer que eu não achei
literatura falando que a prata coleidia
resolver essa bactéria específica aí o
metano breve bacter.
Então esse essa bactéria é um arquial,
né, ou arqueia do gênero arqueia,
aquelas bactérias ancestrais assim como
se fosse bactérias dinossauro, né? E ela
é mais difícil de erradicar.
Essas arqueias, né, ou arqueais,
elas são, acho que arqueias é o termo
mais correto, elas são biofilmes
resistentes que protegem ela dos
antimicrobianos.
Então você pode utilizar a prata
coloidal, pode, mas você não vai ter
evidência científica sólida dizendo.
Então é uma tentativa,
você pode tentar utilizar. Agora, em
relação
ao óleo de orégano, já existe sim
literatura. seria uma excelente opção
secundária. Tem estudos que mostram que
o óleo de orégano tem boa atividade
antimicrobiana, inclusive contra as
arqueias.
Então poderia ser eficaz tanto contra as
bactérias produtoras de hidrogênio
quanto as metanogênicas, que é o caso
das arqueias. Então, a dose terapêutica
é de 200 mg por dia do óleo de orégano,
dividido em duas ou três tomadas em
cápsulas entéricas para evitar irritação
do estômago. E o composto ativo é o
cavacrol, que eu já falei em vídeos
anteriores, tá? Vídeo mais antigo, vocês
podem procurar no canal que o cavacrol
tem eficácia contra biofilmes
bacterianos.
E tem a alicina também, que é o extrato
do alho, né? Alicina é uma substância
presente no alho. Também tem uma
atividade interessante contra essa
arqueia aí, essa metanum breve bter até
mais alta do que o óleo de orégano.
Então você poderia utilizarina
concentrada
450 a 900 mg três vezes ao dia por cerca
de seis semanas.
Infelizmente no Brasil na manipulação, a
gente não tem assim uma lista super
concentrada.
Aí seria melhor comprar o Alimax Pro,
né, que você importa dos Estados Unidos
se você puder.
Então, a Licina é a mais estudada e a
considerada mais eficaz contra as
arquias metanogênicas que produzem o
metano, né? Então, seria o padrão ouro
de fitoterápico para essa bactéria que
você falou aí.
Então use o Alimax Pro ou Alimed, que é
a forma do Alimax que eles vendem são
para médicos lá nos Estados Unidos.
O alho comum não funcionaria porque ele
tem FD map e também porque teria que
ingerir muito alho e você ia passar mal
quase certeza pela quantidade de alho
que você teria que comer, né? Você pode
associar a licina 600 mg três vezes ao
dia, o óleo de orégano 200 mg duas vezes
ao dia. E pode usar aí como terceiro
item menos fraco aí, aliás, mais fraco
no caso para arqueia, que seria a
berberina ou biuberon, tá? Beberina 500
mg três vezes ao dia. Ou bioberon, que é
uma forma mais concentrada de beberina,
150 mg três vezes ao dia, porque ele
ajuda a alicina a atuar.
e 3 meses para low fold map.
Se você fez só low fod map, pode ser um
tempo um pouquinho mais longo do que
deveria. Era bom você já ter iniciado
uma fase de reintrodução gradual de
alimentos e ir fazendo o diário
alimentar para ver como é que você tá
reagindo a cada alimento. Ficar muito
tempo em lpod lopod map, né, estrita,
pode prejudicar a diversidade
microbiana. Então é bom você começar a
reintrodução, tomando muito cuidado, né,
para você não reproduzir mais de um
alimento de uma vez.
E se tiver algum alimento que é muito
difícil de você ingerir, você elimina
definitivamente, né, a dieta, né,
para quem tem eh cibo com predominância
de metano, que eu não sei se é o seu
caso, mas essa bactéria aí ela produz
metano,
geralmente é um cibo, né, eh, associado
à constipação, não sei se é o seu caso.
Então, geralmente é interessante usar
também agentes, é, que aumentam o
trânsito intestinal, né, os miméticos
intestinais, né, você pode utilizar o
gengibre, né, 1 a 2 g ao dia.
E aí tem aquele produto da manipulação
que é um gengibre especial que é o, me
fugiu o nome agora, daqui a pouco eu
olho.
Você pode utilizar o LDN na tradição de
baixa dosagem, tem efeito procinético
também. Magnésio também pode te ajudar,
tá bom? Magnésio, glicina.
Pesquisar se não tem hipocloridria, né?
Pouco ácido no estômago,
que então pode ser necessário usar o
cloridrato de betaína ou enzimas
digestivas. OK?
E infelizmente, tá, o cibo
eh tem muita recidiva, tá?
Então isso é uma coisa muito chata aí
que frustrante o tratamento aí do
intestino irritável.
Pergunta: vinagre de maçã para ajudar a
digestão e refluxo. Tem alguma diferença
entre tomar uma colher na água ou em
cápsulas? Minha nutricionista recomendou
na água, porém minha preocupação seria
de causar mais dano ao isôfago. Comentei
com ela e ela receitou o mocosave. Não
seria mais fácil apenas tomar em
cápsula? Bem, a resposta rápida para
isso é que o vinagre de maçã em cápsula
tem bem menos atividade do que o vinagre
de maçã mesmo, tá? Tem uma diferença.
Então, entre os dois, é bem melhor você
tomar o vinagre de maçã diluído com água
do que usar a cápsula, porque a
literatura diz que a cápsula não tem a
mesma eficiência.
Primeiro ponto é que o vinagre de maçã
diluído em água, ele tem uma solução
mais rápida, mais direta. que tem um
estudo que foi publicado em 2010 no
Journal of Nutritional Science,
que demonstrou que o acetato sérico, né,
acetato do sangue
que foi absorvido, né,
através da ingestão do ácido acético do
vinagre,
atinge o pico em apenas 15 minutos que
você consome na forma líquida, enquanto
nas cápsulas o pico ocorre aos 30
minutos e a absorção é mais lenta e
gradual. Então, ambas as fórmulas podem
atingir concentrações séricas acima de
200 micromoles por litro, que seria a
concentração fisiologicamente ativa, mas
seria muito mais fácil fazer isso com o
vinagre de maçã mesmo.
Porém, tem um estudo muito importante,
2020, publicado no Journal of Nutrition
and Metabolism, que mostrou que os
comprimidos de vinagre não tiveram os
mesmos benefícios fisiológicos que o
vinagre líquido no controle do açúcar
pós alimentação, pósprandial. Então,
vinagre líquido reduziu em 31% a parte
da glicemia,
tá? Então foi muito interessante.
Enquanto as cápsulas inteiras não
tiveram esse efeito significativo.
Em relação a isófago, a preocupação é
válida. O vinagre de maçã pode sim
irritar o esôfago.
Em pessoas que estão com a válvula aí
com deficiência, com válvula
problemática, né? válvula esofagiana,
pessoas têm refluxo. Então é
interessante usar o mocosave, que é um
produto que protege a mucosa do esôfago,
que é uma combinação de polissacarídeos
numa planta chamada palma forrageira.
Então ele tem polifenóis das folhas de
oliveira também junto. Então esses
polissacaros
formam uma substância gelatinosa que
protege a mucosa. Então reveste essa
mucosa e protege também da ação do aço
do estômago na mucosa do esôfago, também
a mucosa gástrica.
Então tem estudos clínicos duplos que
mostraram que o Mucospave reduziu
significativamente a frequência e a
severidade sintomas de refluxo já nos
primeiros dias de uso. Então você
poderia até utilizar as cápsulas de
vinagre de maçã de boa qualidade se você
não tiver nenhuma maneira de utilizar o
vinagre
pela boca ou se você odeia o sabor do
vinagre de maçã.
Mas o problema é tem que tomar várias
cápsulas, né? teri que tá tomando pelo
menos 750 mg de ácido acético. Então
isso significaria várias cápsulas de
vinagre de maçã.
E procure as cápsulas de vinagre de maçã
que tenha eh aquele aquele fundinho do
vinagre de maçã que eles chamam de
mother, né? Tá certo?
Então tem a vantagem também do vinagre
de maçã em casa, proteger o esmag dos
dentes, evitar o contato direto com o
isôfago, mas para você ter mais
benefício de baixar o açúcar do sangue,
seria melhor usar o vinagre líquido.
E utilize mucosave cerca de 15 a 20
minutos antes de utilizar o vinagre
diluído com água. E utilize o canudinho
para tomar esse vinagre diluído com
água, OK? Uma colher de sopa de vinagre
e 200 ml de água tomada 15 a 30 minutos
antes das refeições.
Então, 15 minutos antes do, desculpa, do
vinagre, tomando mucosave e 15 a 30
minutos do vinagre aí que você vai comer
a o bolso ou jantar.
Então, resumindo, cápsula praticidade,
certo? e o líquido mais eficaz. Seria
essa grande diferença.
Doutor, chá de eucalipto atrapalha o
sono. Quais são as recomendações e o chá
de cedrir atrapalha?
Tem um estudo interessante, né, de 2024
e foi publicado no Frontiers ou em
Pharmacology, que mostrou que o óleo
essencial de eucalípto tem efeito sim de
ajudar no sono, porque ele tem efeito
sedativo e hipnótico. Hipnótico seria de
induzir o sono, tá? Então a pesquisa
mostrou que eucalipto na forma aí de
óleo essencial aumenta os
neurotransmissores escalmantes, no caso
do gaba, da glicina, do triptofano que
vira gava depois
e modula a microbiota intestinal de
forma benéfica para o sono.
Portanto, é interessante,
ao contrário do que muitos pensam, o
eucalipto não atrapalha o sono, mas
ajuda sim.
Ele ajuda também na congestão nasal que
algumas pessoas têm na hora de dormir.
Então é é outra situação interessante aí
caso você tenha nariz estupido à noite,
o óleo essencial, né, vai ajudar a
melhorar a respiração.
Então é o Cineal presente, cineol, tá?
Cineol presente no eucalipto que ajuda a
desobstruir as vias aéreas. e o chá de
cidreira, né, que a gente chama de
melissa oficinales. Lembrando que pode
ter outras plantas aí que são
confundidas com cidreira. É um dos
melhores chá para sono. Também tem
estudos de 2024 mostrando que a cidreira
reduz sono em 42%, melhora também a
qualidade do sono, aumentando os níveis
de gaba através da inibição da enzima
GABA transaminase.
Ou seja, aumenta o GABA através da
inibição de uma enzima que degrada o
GABA.
Tem um estudo recente com fitossoma de
milíça que mostrou aumento de 15% na
fase do sono profundo e em 87% dos
participantes
que tiveram melhora da qualidade de
sono.
Então a dose recomendada é de 600 mg de
extrato seco
por dia da cidreira. OK?
Então a cidreira não atrapalha, tá? Ele
ajuda e a mesma coisa do eucalipto.
Dr. Alan, cerca de três semanas tive uma
semana de espirros muito intensos. Em um
dos dias, ao nariz no banheiro, notei
pequenas gotículas quase imperceptíveis
de sangue no muco.
Foi episódio único. Nesse mesmo período,
durante um espirro muito forte, passei a
sentir dor no lado esquerdo do tórax. Na
região do coração, dói a papação, piora
com uma respiração profunda em certas
posições. Não tive febre. Desde então o
catarro, os espirros cessaram, a dor
diminuiu, mas ainda persiste levemente
quando respira o fundo ou pressiono o
local. Fui atendido no SUS, relatei os
sintomas, mas não houve exame do local e
não solicitaram radiografia, apesar de
eu ter pedido. Na sua avaliação, isso
pode indicar algo grave? Gente, eu vou
responder aqui, mas eu peço para vocês
evitarem esse tipo de pergunta assim
muito longa, muito específica de como se
fosse uma consulta médica, tá? Mas vamos
falar aí
bem, quando você espirra muito, tá?
Algumas pessoas desenvolvem uma dor
torácica, que pode ser isso que você
teve,
que a gente chama de cosocondrite,
tá? De tanto você espirrar, de tanto se
você fazer movimentos assim bruscos do
tórax, caso espirro, na verdade é uma
expiração forçada, você pode dar uma
lesão muscular nas musculaturas ali que
tem entre as costelas, que é a
musculatura intercostal. Então, espirros
muito intensos repetitivos podem
provocar isso,
causando microtraumas nessas junções
cosocondrais e nos músculos. essa
costaocondrite, essa inflamação das
cartilagens, né, ou do músculo que
conecta às costelas,
é benigno, é autoimitado, mas pode ser
bem desconfortável.
Eu me lembro que uma vez eu levei minha
avó, quando ela tava viva ainda, eu era
ainda residente de cirurgia geral na
Universidade de Brasília, no HUB.
Ela teve um quadro desse custo com dri,
eu levei ela ao PS.
Isso já tem mais de 20 anos. Deve ter
já,
ah, deve ter quase 30 anos já. É isso
aí,
minha saudosa avó, mãe da minha mãe. Vem
o fato de você sentir dor ao apertar o
local, né, ao respirar profundamente,
dependendo da posição, é bem
característico da cortocondrite, então
não é perigoso, tá? Nada grave.
E sobre as pequenas gotículas de sangue
que você observou,
isso pode ter acontecido pelo
ressecamento, irritação da mucosa nasal
pelos espios repetitivos, porque quando
a gente espirra com muita força, criamos
turbulência e pressão que podem romper
pequenos capilares na região anterior do
nariz.
Isso é autolimitado, comum e não é
grave, tá? Você pode utilizar
antiinflamatórios comuns, né, por tempo
limitado, 5 a 7 dias. É o caso do
bioprofeno, nimesulida, por aí vai, né?
Eh, pode aplicar calor local na região
dolorosa, que ajuda por 15 a 20 minutos,
três a quatro vezes por dia, evitar os
movimentos bruscos, carregar peso,
exercício intenso em duas semanas, mas
isso vai recuperar, isso vai sumir
provavelmente sozinho, tá?
E para evitar episódio de epistáxe, que
é eliminar sangue pelo nariz, mantenha a
mucosa nasal hidratada com soro
fisiológico três vezes ao dia ou quatro
vezes ao dia. Tome vitamina C, pode
ajudar 1 a 2 g ao dia. Vitamina D também
para manter os níveis de vitamina D no
sangue adequados. Pode ser 5000 a 10.000
por dia, dependendo dessa situação aí do
sangue.
Magnésio pode ajudar porque ele é um
relaxante muscular.
E geralmente o problema se resolve em
torno de um mês, de quatro a três
semanas, com tratamento de suporte
mesmo, tá?
O fato positivo é que você não deve ter
tido febre e provavelmente a dor está
diminuindo
gradualmente. E procure assistência
médica se a dor piorar, tá? ou se você
tiver febre, ou se você tiver que estado
geral, ou se você tiver falta de ar
progressiva, ou se sai muito sangue na
no catarro, aí tem que pôr assistência
médica, tá?
Dr. Alan, jovem de 28 anos, com déficit
de atenção severo, não consegue se
concentrar na leitura,
muito ansioso, não sabe se é autismo,
essa pergunta de misturar PDH com
autismo,
várias semanas recebendo esse tipo de
pergunta. Eu já falei muito desse
assunto, mas vamos falar mais sobre ele,
né? Quais seriam as minhas dicas então
para esse jovem que aparentemente pode
ter autismo e TDH?
Então
existe hoje, né, um aumento muito grande
de diagnóstico. Recebi essa semana
inclusive uma menina de 18 anos que ela
foi exatamente diagnosticada com uma
mistura de TDAH TEIA.
Então nem sempre esse diagnóstico tá
correto, né? Tá existindo aí uma
tendência a diagnosticar essas coisas.
E estudos recente em 2024 mostram que 30
85% das pessoas que estão no espectro
autista também podem ter TDH. Olha só o
que número variável, 30 85. Então para
mim isso é quase chute, né?
E cerca de 30% dos adultos que tm TDAH
podem ter características autísticas.
Então tá tudo muito embolado aí mesmo,
né? Já falamos muito sobre isso, tem
vídeos antigos no canal que fala sobre
isso, mas que que poderia utilizar para
TDAH, melhorar o foco e a tensão e
melhorar também parcialmente os sintomas
autísticos, né? Magnésio, né? Você pode
usar o glicinato ou glicina ou treonato,
pode usar o magnésio taurato também
ajudam na hiperatividade, na ansiedade,
na qualidade do sono. Utilizar por volta
de 400 mg do magnésio alimentar por dia.
Nessas formas que eu falei.
Vitamina D é sempre importante, mantém
bons níveis, porque existe estudos de
2025 mostrando que adultos com
deficiência de vitamina D tem mais TDH
ou inversamente adultos que tm TDH tem
níveis significativamente mais baixo de
vitamina D. Então tem que checar a
vitamina D e suplementar.
pode melhorar só com vitamina D, 30% aí
a hiperatividade, a desatenção
e também ansiedade. Omega-3 é muito
importante
pelo efeito antiinflamatório
cerebral, né? Redução da
neuroinflamação. Tome tome pelo menos 2
g de ômega-3 por dia, rico em Dga
e que tenham pelo menos 1 g de EPA
nessas duas cápsulas também. Complexo B
é importante
porque eles são precursores nascentes de
neurotransmissores. O zinco tem que tá
adequado também porque regula dopamina.
E eu falo sempre muito aqui no canal da
Ltanina, muito bom com anciolítico
natural. aumenta o foco sem deixar sono
lento. Então, acalma, aumento o foco sem
deixar sono lento. Mas você pode usar de
200 a 400 mg sem
acompanhamento, com acompanhamento pode
até subir essa dose aí. Gosto muito de
liteanina, então a chagana também ajuda,
pode reduzir a ansiedade. A rodola rosa
também pode ajudar e tirar os alimentos
inflamatórios açúcar, processar as
refinados industrializados, tirar o
glúteo e tirar a casina que vem do
derivados do leite.
E estudos de 2024 mostram a melhora
significativa de TDH e comportamento
ansioso
em quem tira esses alimentos
inflamatórios. OK?
Lembrando que boa parte dos problemas
psiquiátricos tá relacionado à barreira
intestinal, né, o liquigut.
E o glúten, mesmo que não é silíaco, ele
abre a barreira intestinal.
Aumente o consumo de proteínas de
qualidade, gordura de qualidade,
abacate, azeite, castanha, vegetais
coloridos, exercício físico é muito
importante,
dando preferência para aeróbico,
vegetação e mindfulness, sono é muito
importante, né? ter 7 a 9 horas de sono,
usar melatonen se for necessário e fazer
investigação completa com exame de
laboratório.
Bem, falando rapidamente que da
diferença do TDAH e do TEA, no TDH a
desatenção é mais por distração e
impulsividade, no TE é mais por hiperco
em interesses específicos. Lembrando que
existe hiperfoco também no TDH, tá?
Então, dificuldades sociais no TDAH vem
da impulsividade e desatenção. No TEA
vem de dificuldade genuína em ler sinais
sociais.
Muita pergunta hoje, pessoal. Acho que
eu nem vou conseguir responder as ao
vivo, tá? Estamos uma hora de live aí,
já não consegui terminar as perguntas do
documento. Dr. Alan, se uma pessoa vai
se consultar com o senhor, pode servir
internet? Sim, eu atendo via online.
Quais são os valores atuais? Eu não
prefiro não falar, tá? Porque prefiro
que você consulte a secretária.
E a quantidade de exames que geralmente
eu passo, é uma lista que dá mais ou
menos 35 exames, tá? Não é tanto exame
assim como alguns colegas pedem. Poderia
me fornecer as informações, por favor?
É, aí eu vou te dar o telefone, tá? E aí
você, eu vou colocar aqui o telefone
para você entrar em contato
com a secretária, tá bom?
Temos dois, tem uma um telefone que cai
direto no atendimento por IA, mas eu vou
te passar o que dá direto na secretária.
Lembrando que pode demorar um pouco mais
porque o do IA é instantâneo, né? Mas
ele não faz agendamento.
Deixa eu achar aqui então o telefone
porque até hoje eu não memorizei porque
o telefone mudou.
WhatsApp. WhatsApp. WhatsApp. Cadê o
WhatsApp?
Acho que não ia ser isso aqui. Pera aí.
Me dá só um minuto que eu vou achar
aqui. Achei.
Então este é o número da clínica, tá?
Vamos até o final aqui para eu poder
mostrar.
Pronto. Vou deixar na tela aqui.
Eh, próxima pergunta. mulher de 54 anos,
diabética, que quebrou o osso do braço
na pergunta anterior. Não sei qual a
pergunta anterior, desculpa. Nem sempre
aparece para mim na mesma ordem que
vocês colocam.
Ah, não sei, talvez seja a pessoa que
tem lá dor torácica, não sei. Às vezes
sente dor, o que significa a dor já faz
um mês e meio que ela fez a cirurgia.
Gente, não faço esse tipo de pergunta
assim super específica de, sabe,
tentando cavar consulta. Eu vou, eu
tento ajudar, sinceramente. Eu tenho uma
boa vontade de ajudar vocês, mas isso
aqui é me pode dar problema e fica muito
confuso para as vezes analisar isso, tá?
Ã, já faz um mês e meio que fez
cirurgia. Cúrcuma substitui anti
substitui anti-inflamatório de farmácia.
A cúrcuma não é tão intenso quanto o
ibuprofena, quanto de mesulide, quanto
um de colofenaco, tá? Para uma dor mais
aguda, usam cinco dias de
antiinflamatório de farmácia mesmo. A
cucumina seria para uso prolongado por
várias semanas, tá?
Então, falando um pouquinho de processo
de consolidação óssea, cirurgia de osso
leve média de 6 a 12 semanas, então é
longo, tá? E é mais lento ainda em
diabéticos por causa da microcirculação
que fica comprometida.
A cúrcuma, eh, utilize ela para uso
prolongado, mas para dor mais aguda, use
analgésicos aí de farmácia comum por até
5 a 7 dias.
E se for usar a cúcuma, usa curcumina eh
na faixa aí. Se for uma cucumina normal,
comum, 1000 a 100 mg por dia. Se for uma
cocumina de alta absorção, você pode
usar aí uns 300 mg por dia.
Tem estudos falando que tem eficácia
similar ao diclofenaco, mas eu
sinceramente para uma dor mais aguda, eu
utilizaria
um diclofenacoo por 5 dias ou
embuprofeno. Mas estudo aí que foi
publicado em 2024 mostrou que após a 8 a
12 semanas de uso a cúrcuma produziu
redução da dor que foi comparável aos
antiinflamatórios tradicionais. Então,
tá vendo que é um estudo que mostrou o
uso prolongado, que aí é isso que eu
recomendo vocês utilizarem a curcumina e
não utilizar para uma dor mais aguda,
como já expliquei.
Lembrando que a cocumina tem um problema
sério de biodisponibilidade. Então, se
você for utilizar curcumina comum, tem
que utilizar ela com gordura e com a
pimenta preta para aumentar a absorção
intestinal. Se você for utilizar uma
forma de absorção aumentada por eh
nanomicelas ou alguma tecnologia que
aumenta aí a absorção, esse problema
diminui bastante.
A côncuma é muito boa em diabéticos, né?
Estudos de 2025 mostraram que é
concumbinativa uma via metabólica
chamada Circ 3 Fox 3A, que protege os
osteoblastos, que são células que
produzem osso do estresso oxidativo
induzido pelo aumento da glicose e
melhora a consolidação óssea em
diabéticos. Então vai muito bem aí a
cúrcupa para diabéticos que estão
precisando de consolidação óssea.
Eu associaria a cúrcuma com outros
ativos. Eu faria uma fórmula com
buzuélielia serrata. Poderia utilizar aí
300 a 500 mg três vezes ao dia junto com
a cucumina. E eu colocaria um pé também
que é o pomitoetanolamina uns 500 mg
também duas vezes ao dia, tá? pode usar
ômega-3 para ajudar na na
antiinflamação, né, na uma ação
anti-inflamatória.
Gengibre tem ação também um pouquinho
mais fraca, mas pode ajudar.
Então, fariam cinco dias aí de buprofena
ou duplofenácimis. Depois entraria com
essa combinação que eu falei aí de
cocumina, bozuélia, peia e pode também
colocar um extrato de gengibre junto,
certo?
Lembrando que demora aí várias semanas
para consolidar.
Próxima pergunta. Exames de sangue podem
identificar pedra nos ins? Não, só
exames de imagem, tá? Ah, ou apenas
problemas de falência em si. Sim, é mais
a questão do funcionamento do rim,
exames de imagem são necessários para
ver a pedra em si, tá?
Então você tem que tá vendo a
creatinina, né, a ureia, algumas vezes a
cistatina C são marcadoras de função
renal, exames de imagem como raiz X,
ultraçom, em alguns casos tomografia,
eh, por exemplo, a urotomografia, vão
ver melhor aí a pedra e também a
anatomia do rim.
Além dos exames que eu acabei de falar
de função renal, você tem os
eletrólitos, né? Sódio, potássio,
cálcio, magnésio. Importante ver isso
daí.
Casos assim de pedras que estão
obstruindo o rim por dentro, pode
aumentar então esses marcadores de
função renal, levando pode ser uma
espícia renal aguda até crônica se for
uma coisa longa.
Também é importante medir muitas vezes o
cálcio
da urina, não só o cálcio do sangue,
porque a pessoas que tm cálcio aumentado
na urina pode ter maior facilidade de
formar pedras. Lembrando que algumas
pessoas que formam pedras t
hiperparatireidismo, que é excesso de
atividade das glândulas paratireoides,
aumentando o cálcio no sangue,
aumentando o cálcio na urina, que é uma
causa tratável de cálculos que se
repetem.
Então tem que medir o paraturbônio, né,
que é o marcador que vai levar a você
enxergar o não hiperparatiroidismo, que
pode ser primário ou secundário.
O parotiroidismo secundário se resolve
com vitamina D, o primário tem que à vez
fazer cirurgia, tirar glândulas da
paratireoide.
Também tem que medir o ácido úrico no
sangue. Áúrico aumentado aumenta um tipo
de pedra também.
eh predispõe a formação de pedras ou
cálculos de urato ou ácido úrico. Isso é
comum em pacientes com gota ou que tem
um consumo exagerado de proteína animal.
medir a vitamina D também, o fósforo do
sangue, o magnésio.
E como eu já falei, é importante
examinar esses minerais na orem de 24
horas para poder avaliar a exção de
cálcio, oxalato, citrato. O citrato é
protetor, tá? Então, quanto mais se
trata na urina e magnésio protetor, os
outros geralmente aumentam o risco, como
é o cálcio, oxalato e o ácido úrico. O
sódi aumentado na urina também é um
risco aumentado de pedra nos insens.
Importante também em muitos casos, repor
com o citrato potássio, que ele é um
fator protetor contra a formação de
pedras.
Eh, lembrando que o suco de limão tem
bastante citrato de potássio.
Bem, eh, Dra. para surgi uma nova
possibilidade de tratamento de ou cura
para autismo ou esquizofrenia ou de
atenção.
Então aí é uma pergunta muito ampla, vou
tentar aí responder da melhor forma
possível. Em relação aos pelo menos pela
medicina ortodoxa, nós temos os
anticorpos monoclonais que não tiveram
grandes assim efeitos nos últimos anos,
são caríssimos e tem um risco alto de 10
a 15% de edema cerebral e sangramento,
que é o caso do lecanemabe, donanemab,
né?
Então eu não sou fã desses remédios, mas
são remédios novos que surgiram para o
tratamento do Alzheimer, porque
removeriam diretamente as placas
amiloides. A gente sabe que a placa
amiloide não é a causa da doença, mas
sim a consequência dos insultos
cerebrais e da tentativa do organismo se
defender desses insultos cerebrais
aumentando as placas amiloides.
Então eu não sou fã desses tratamentos.
Existe um monte de remédio reposicionado
que não estudado para Alzheimer, né?
Exemplo azul de mexileno.
Eh, tem também orottio,
tem própria vimctina que tá começando a
ser estudada, tem muita coisa aí que
pode ajudar, mas não isoladamente, tá?
Tem os ferápicos aí todos que a gente já
usa, né, para diminuir a inflamação
cerebral, o próprio ômega-3. Tem um
estudos interessantes com a semagrutida
que você sabe que foi inicialmente para
diabetes, depois foi para baixar peso,
né? E que poderia ter então agrotida em
pacientes com resistência, diabetes
cerebral, né, que a gente chama
resistência cerebral, poderia ter feito
então um neuroprotetor.
Em termos de autismo, né, a novidade
seria a personalização através de testes
genéticos.
infelizmente só responde por 20% dos
casos.
Tecnologias como realidade virtual,
inteligência artificial estão ajudando a
fazer as terapias comportamentais nos
autistas. E tem também uma um anticorpo
monoclonal chamado Nirvimab.
Também é muito novo, muito caro. Tem
mostrado aí alguns resultados bons
para melhorar a comunicação social e
comportamentos repetitivos. estão também
testando terapia com células tronco de
codão umbilical, mas também no início
disso. E o orotato de líico, comentei
que tava sendo estudado para Alheimer,
também tá sendo utilizado
eh para o autismo,
porque tem esse efeito aí de eh modular
aí o sistema imune cerebral e diminuir a
neuroinflamação.
Em termos de esquizofrenia,
tem aí uns remédios novos também, tem o
cobenfia ou cobenfy, não sei se
pronuncia cobenfia ou cobenfy, mas é
fyção
do chan nomelini com trpum, foi aprovado
nos Estados Unidos na FDI ano passado, é
o primeiro medicamento com mecanismo de
ação completamente novo desde o ano 50
para essa situação, em vez de bloquear a
dopamina, que é o neurotransmissor aí
relacionado
a esquizofrenia, que também esse
bloqueio causa terríveis defeitos
colaterais
que os antipsicótipos tradicionais
provocam.
Ele atuaria nos receptores
muscarínico de ácilocolina.
Então, os resultados mostraram redução
significativa de sintomas sem causar
ganho de peso, sonolência ou movimentos
involuntários.
Não tem experiência com esse remédio,
nem sei se chegou no Brasil.
E tem outros agonistas muscarínicos e
moduladores de GPR52 em desenvolvimento.
Tem também o benzoato de sódio
cristalino que tá sendo utilizado em
estudos, mostrando capacidade de tratar
sintomas positivos, negativos e
cognitivos da esquizofrenia, que atua
modulando o sistema NMDA através
dacerina. Lembrando assim que muitos
portadores de esquizofrenia respondem à
vitamina B de bola 3 em altas doses,
outros respondem com antioxidação
intensa e outros respondem com reposição
de zinco, tá? Tem um livro muito
interessante
que é do Dr. Walch.
Se tem interesse, dá uma lida nesse
livro, Dr. Walch, que ele trata
essas condições todas aí com nutrientes,
tá?
Desce de atenção. Que que tem de
novidade? Sou rianfetol.
Solanfetol
teve uma redução de 45% nos sintomas em
adultos. É um inibidor tripo da
recaptação de dopamina, noripnefina e
serotonina.
Tem outro também chamado tentanafadina.
Gente, parece até piadinha isso aí de
quinta série, né?
Eh, então também tá em final, fase final
de aprovação nos Estados Unidos, tá?
Para essa situação de défic de atenção.
Lembrando que tem os naturais que eu
comentei já na live, né? É só voltar aí
o vídeo e assistir.
Tem também o Onida XR, que é o primeiro
medicamento não estimulante para essa
questão do TDH,
para aqueles que não toleram os
estimulantes
e tá já disponível nos Estados Unidos
também.
E a tendência, como vocês sabem, é a
medicina personalizada, né?
E o foco tá cada vez maior em
neuroinflamação, microbioma intestinal e
medicina de alta precisão.
Bem, vamos pra próxima pergunta. Não
acaba as perguntas hoje, né, pessoal? Tô
com já quase 1 hora meia de live. Dout.
Alan, tomar banho com água quente quando
ela foi afetada pelo calor da tarde e
ela já não está mais totalmente fria,
pode dar gripe ou piorar gripe. Lavar a
mão com água da torneira quente pelo sol
pode dar gripe ou piorar. Quando uma
pessoa sente a garganta estranha
iniciando a gripe, qual remédio caseiro
você recomenda? Limão com alho e mel
deó. O que que acrescenta mais? Maneira
correta de fazer para cortar a gripe e
recomende outro remédio natural para
cortar a gripe.
Olha, um remédio natural para cortar
gripe muito bom é vitamina C.
Vitamina C muito boa em outras doses aí
ela corta pelo menos uns dois dias de
gripe intensa. Própolis verde também é
muito bom.
A evimectina, eu cada vez tô ficando
mais seguro em relação a isso.
Avimectina também é um ótimo antiviral.
Vamos desmistificar essa questão da água
quente. Não tem evidência científica de
que tomará o banho com água morna ou
lavar as mãos com água aquecida pelo sol
vai causar gripe. Não sei você tirou
isso, desculpa, mas é é bem curioso essa
afirmação.
A gripe, na verdade existe essa questão
do choque térmico, né? Mas não é todo
mundo que tem choque térmico que vai
ficar mais suscetível à virose,
né?
A ciência demonstra que o vírus da
gripe, né, o influenza, se transmite
melhor em ambientes frios e secos
com a umidade então do ar baixa. Isso
não tem relação com a temperatura da
água do banho.
Outra coisa que eu não comentei, você
pode fazer uso de uma infusão, ou seja,
um chá com três dentes de alho frescos
esmagados, né, para gripe. O suco de
dois limãos, limões frescos, duas
colheres de sopa de mel de manuca, se
você conseguir. Mas aí se você utilizar
o suco de limão com gengibre e dente de
alho, vai ter um bom efeito. O alho tem
alicina, que eu já comentei aqui pro pra
pergunta em relação ao cibo. Então o
alicina, além de ser excelente para
matar bactérias intestinais aí ruins,
ela tem propriedades antivirais também
comprovadas contra o vírus da influenza
A e B, o rinovírus e o HSV1.
O gengibre tem composto como gingerol,
que tem ação potente, antiinflamatória e
antiviral, especialmente contra os vírus
respiratórios essenciais.
Pode utilizar também a cúrcuma, cupeta
preta para ajudar na antiinflamação.
Já falei da vitamina C em altas doses,
né? Você pode tomar cinco ah 6 ou 10 g
por dia, viorar, mas aí lembrando que a
vitamina C dá diarreia em doses altas,
aí você pode tomar até uma certa dose
que começa a dar diarreia, você recua na
dose da vitamina C. A vitamina D também
você pode tomar 50.000 de uma vez, pode
dar uma ajudada a cortar gripe rápida.
zinco. Se você tiver com deficiência de
zinco, você pode tomar 50 mg de zinco
por dia por alguns dias, que ajuda
queina, que é um antiinflamatório muito
interessante, extraído da cebola e da
maçã. A quecetina tem ação natural
antihistamínica, né? Ajuda os sintomas
alérgicos e ajuda a entrar o zinco nas
células, né?
O NC pode ajudar a fluidificar as
secreções.
Já falei do própolis, que é muito bom
com antiriral.
Você pode usar também o berry, que é o
extrato de sabugueiro, tem ação anti
viral, tem vídeos no canal sobre isso,
tá?
Então é basicamente isso daí, tá? Você
pode também fazer gargarejo com água
morna, sal marinha ou sal integral. Pode
colocar duas gotas de óleo essencial de
orégano ou tomilho que tem ação
antimicrobiana, né? Esse gagarejo.
Pode usar spray de própolis diretamente
na garganta, fica bem hidratado ou
hidratada.
Pode usar chá de equinácia que tem
efeito imunoestimulante ou ou chá de
estragalos.
Pode usar causa de osso ajuda.
E alimentação não inflamatória cortando
o açúcar, né?
e os outros alimentos inflamatórios que
já falamos aí durante a live, repouso
adequado, muito importante
tentar eh deixar a febre atuar um pouco,
porque a febre moderada ajuda a combater
o vírus. Então, não fique eh tratando a
febre a todo custo, porque ela ajuda.
Então é isso, pessoal. Ah, tá bom, né?
Deixa eu ver se tem mais alguma coisa ao
vivo aqui. Tem muita coisa que eu não vi
aqui durante a transmissão. Pa pa pa pa
pá.
Podemos fazer uma enquete sobre quem
está com checkup em dia cardiovascular.
Saber que os riscos genéticos são
importantes.
Ultração de carotes e vertebrais padrão
ouro até em crianças.
avaliar endotel e suas patologias.
Vitamina D. Assunto hoje aqui discutido.
Melhorar saúde da endotélio com
tá. OK.
Tar Paula, sempre com as suas
contribuições para nossas lives.
Aí pessoal, compartilhe os vídeos, faça
bem. A vida de alguém pode melhorar.
também com o canal do Dr. Alando. Trá se
envolva.
Ah, Lipedema.
Eh, disse evitar a suplementação
excessiva. Sim, não é melhor evitar da
vitamina D ficar acima de 100 no sangue.
Tá
sim. Eu tenho uma assinatura de ovos lá
em casa e os ovos são caipira, que é
praticamente é ovo orgânico, que é a
mesma coisa.
Sim. É a galinha que cisca, né? Tá
certo?
Muitas vezes os fazendeiros eles
complementam a alimentação da galinha
com grãos, né? Você tem razão, mas se
você puder ter essa informação
diretamente do produtor, melhor ainda.
As minhas, até onde eu sei, elas ciscam.
Não minhas que eu crio, né? Mas do da
assinatura de ovos que eu que eu compro.
É porque no caso aí, Eliseu, deve ser um
ovo branco, né? Então são galinhas que
seriam normalmente aí de granja, mas que
talvez como uma alimentação
diferenciada. Talvez seja isso.
Ah, ovo com abacate é uma boa
combinação. É, às vezes pode dar
diarreia algumas pessoas, mas é uma boa
combinação.
É boa porque tem a todos os nutrientes
do ovo e tem também os nutrientes do
abacate,
né, que vão ajudar na ação dos
nutrientes do ovo. É basicamente isso.
[Música]
Tá, três que pesquisares.
Tá aventurando na Paula dando mais
informações aí sobre a assinatura de
ovo.
Ovos de tu
telefone da clínica.
Que pena. Longe para mim. Não, mas aí já
deve ter algum produtor rural aí perto
da sua casa, Eraçatuba, que vai te
fornecer os ovos, né? Até mais fácil
para você, não é uma assinatura, né? Mas
você consegue.
Obrigado pelo comentário, viu? Foi bem
mais longa, né? Deu quase 1 hora e meia.
Problema para quem vai assistir depois,
né? Vai ter que ter paciência. Bem,
pessoal, muito obrigado pela presença de
vocês. Vejo vocês na semana que vem. Um
abraço, um beijo no coração. Até a
próxima.
Obrigado, Antônio Renato. Bênçãos para
você também e para todos que estão
assistindo essa live.